we begin this morning with a new
face-to-face denial of Russian
interference in the US election
President Trump and President Vladimir
Putin spoke during part of Trump's
five-nation visit to the Far East
President Trump just landed in Hanoi
Vietnam but hours ago the two presidents
met in Danang at an economic summit of
Asian leaders Putin denied meddling in
the u.s. presidential election last year
and even said the alleged links between
trumps former campaign manager Paul
Manafort and Russia were fabricated
major Garrett is traveling with the
president
major good morning good morning the
operative word for President Trump
during his time here at the Asia
economic summit no no direct talks with
Russian President Vladimir Putin no
meeting with any other head of state
here and no discernible progress on
one-on-one trade deals meant to replace
the multinational trans-pacific
partnership mr. Trump withdrew the
United States from earlier this year
now the president and Putin did have
their casual encounter shaking hands and
talking briefly as they walked alongside
one another to the group shot of many
heads of state gathered here for
economic and security talks the US and
Russia did release a joint statement on
Syria that offered vague plans for a new
constitution and a political settlement
one that read a lot like ones put
forward during the Obama administration
and for their part the Russians did all
the talking releasing news of the
statement and text hours before the
White House aboard Air Force One on his
flight from here to the Vietnamese
capital of Hanoi the president told
reporters he did ask Putin if he ordered
meddling in the 2016 US election he said
he didn't meddle I asked him again you
can only ask so many times I just asked
him again he did not do what they are
saying he did the president said adding
that Putin quote is very insulted by it
which is not a good thing for our
country now one of the reasons mr. Trump
did not meet with other heads of state
here as many of them were involved in
their own conversations on putting
together a successor to the
trans-pacific partnership which means if
those talks are successful that deal
designed to be an economic counterweight
to China if it's achieved will not
include the United States
Anthony major Garrett in Danang Vietnam
Thanks